was there a pivotal moment where you
said this is what I want to do for the
rest of my life yeah I was a sophomore
in high school they had a talent show
and I kind of kept my filmmaking
somewhat low key and not really like
shared that with many people because
back then it was kind of a door key
thing to do it wasn't like today where
there's youtube and everybody's doing it
it was something you didn't want to like
let most people know about because you
know it was more along the lines of that
like Star Wars kid that got like made
fun of a lot on youtube like that's what
people thought you were doing with your
films if you told people you made movies
feel bad for that kid because he was
just messing around his garage I know
but it's kind of what we were doing and
I didn't want people to know that
because i was making mistakes you know i
was doing a lot of stuff that i knew
wasn't quite up to standard and i wanted
to like do that stuff in the privacy of
my own home but i also did with friends
and I trusted and we watched the stuff
and I would share it with people that I
was close to and get better slowly but
talent show I decided that I would do
something for that and I would make a
movie for that and that I would
basically out myself as a filmmaker and
it was a one of the most nervous moments
of my life I was so nervous to show
people as the room full of 8-under
people I went from like doing little
projects on my little iMac and showing
one or two people and kind of like
having a lap together to all the sudden
I was going to show this project that I
made to 800 people of my fellow
classmates who everybody has been to
high school knows like high school ain't
easy socially and you know that's a
pretty risky maneuver for a young person
you know I wasn't like a super popular
kid back then I had a I had friends in
all different friend circles but I was
kind of like slipping between the cracks
i wasn't like making myself known very
often and I didn't I liked it that way I
didn't want to be a prominent social
figure in high school not that I could
have been anyway even if I want to
regardless you know I showed this movie
in town show and I know I remember that
there was like a part way through the
movie I got so nervous that I like went
to the bathroom and puked and I was like
wow like that I've never felt any kind
of emotion that made me that affected
where I was like a physical reaction and
I heard like the audience erupted into
like applause and I went in and I her
and I watched it and people were like
really liked it and I was like whoa like
that was really cool and I think i sat
down and all my friends were like
patting me on the back and stuff people
are clapping and the credits were
rolling and uh all that nerve isn't it
went away I was like the greatest relief
had ever felt and
I think huh I think that sort of helped
you know like make my mind commit to
going after what I wanted to do
naturally what I felt I was good at and
what I wanted to do inside so I made a
decision I think right then that I was
going to go pursue movies that's what
maybe want to try to graduate call or
high school so early was because I had a
sophomore when that happened that was
like halfway through my sophomore year
and I'm had to endure the rest of that
year and the following junior year and I
by that point I had had enough I was
like I had already committed to that in
my mind at that point and I was working
so hard on all these projects that i was
doing and but after that movie showed
everybody would come to meet him to make
their film were to work on whatever
video project ahead i had people like
you know i would do i did a film for the
theater project like the the play that
they did it was a it was grease or
something and had a drive-in movie and I
made the drive-in movie for the grease
screen and I went from being like
somebody nobody even really knew their
name maybe they saw me in the hallway to
like people constantly asking me for
that stuff and knowing that I was that
guy that made movies and I was like a
cool thing to me because I had died i
was being my true self and it was
accepted and that felt really cool so i
guess because of that affirmation and
that you know confidence building
experience i was able to basically say
hey if this works here i can probably do
this for for a living and feel this way
forever hopefully does it was a pretty
intense experience you know he was like
14 or 15 years old and that's also a
very intense time emotionally as a human
being you know things are so amplified
imagine the most intense thing you've
ever felt amplified by you know an
emotional state of a early teenager
so it's pretty intense that's social
acceptance see I was like so it's so
crucial so did you go to be then when
people you may be blended in more than
they knew your name in the hallway where
you get a little bit ly fives and the
pat on the back sort yeah a little bit
of that um again i wasn't really after
that so I didn't pursue it or try to
perpetuate it if it did happen once or
twice after that it's more about people
understood what I was capable of in that
realm and they would see potential and
making things that they were doing
better if I was involved so like you
know like the play for example I was
asked by i think it was either the
professor or Dan Davidson who ended up
being in my other my first feature
finger man to do it and it I think it
made the play better because it was
something exciting on the screen that I
added to the experience of what would
normally be something that they were
making up verbally you know that they
can actually sit and watch the movie and
comment on it for real so the audience
was getting a different experience that
was a little more multimedia and and
kind of you know unusual for that time
period people incorporating the sort of
thing into a live performance it's kind
of cool it was different and new and
something challenging for them as well
and then other people would ask me to do
commercials for their like whatever
sports event was going on or I think
there was like a thing in the government
class or the economics class where they
were selling t-shirts and I would do
commercials for the t-shirts and it was
like you know we would emulate things
like bullet time and the matrix and
stuff like that to make things exciting
whereas normally they might just be put
together really haphazardly and not
really interesting but I was also in
charge of the morning announcements
after that so we would do really cool
stuff and I was like a little bit
rebellious so I would do stuff like my
mom had this old like monochrome
computer screen and I came in and part
of the morning announcements he's time
like this like weird title thing where I
was just like kind of I thought it was
wack I was just like crow like one of
those things called old school like
graphics machines that i want to say
they're like
starts with the chyron chyron chyron
graphics right they would just do this
like we were like switching between the
graphics and I was like now that's kind
of wack why don't we smash a TV with a
baseball bat and so we did that but we
did it with like cool like editing and
everything and then I would show stuff
like Ferris Bueller you know talking
about how to bake the parents out and
you know things like that
you